[Music]
knows it won't be an easy race the
Member of Parliament representing
turkey's main opposition the Republican
people's party or CHP is seeking real
action he tells people in this Ankara
suburb that there is a big chance the
opposition will win but he is worried
about the fairness of the vote
we believe in Turkish democracy turkey
still has a democratic tradition
regardless of how biased is the
Judiciary but if rules are respected we
should not be concerned about
irregularities the question is will the
government respect the results
at the headquarters of the higher
electoral commission an exhibition
features old voting stamps ballot papers
and a photo archive so younger
Generations can connect with history
voters will choose their president from
this list of four candidates
then they will have to decide the party
they will be voting for from this list
of 24 political parties in the general
elections and then
they will have to cast their ballot and
by the end of the day
representatives from political parties
along with public officials will do the
count they will have to ensure that
there are no irregularities if before
announcing the results
is a member of vote and Beyond an NGO
that monitors elections he's joining an
army of volunteers to ensure the vote
will be fair and transparent uh
we're aiming to deploy 100 000
volunteers to cover all the polling
stations we have a responsibility at
this moment since Paul say this could be
a tight race
is one of the youngest candidates of the
governing AK party she is spending time
with her constituency getting to know
people
I want to stand for the Youth I'm an
engineer I've been involved in politics
for the last seven years I want to
listen to Young people's problems and
provide Solutions in the final stages of
campaigning tensions are rising
protesters through stones
in the city of erzerum last week
the Istanbul mayor will become vice
president if the opposition Alliance
wins accused the police chief and the
governor of allowing violence the
response senior AG party member Suleiman
soilu called Imam a provocative Ankara
it's still ahead here in altazira
just